you don't have your keys right okay
gabe and i are clearing out that loading
dock and there's a lot of stuff in there
and it's super dusty we've got this
problem we don't have any room in the
loading dock because there's all this
crap in here that was supposed to be
thrown away a long time ago the thing
about these is you can't really fit them
in the garbage bin as is so
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
oh camera down me and sam and nico are
all from minnesota and in minnesota we
have a tradition in stillwater where
we're from it's called lumberjack days
and it happens every year at the end of
july seeing as it's the end of july i
found it only appropriate that we do
some real damage in honor
of our ancestors
in my former life i was defended by a
lawyer after i asked murdered somebody
[Music]
so we're about to play nerf trouble in
terrace town now the concept is
basically mafia combined with nerf
[Music]
i'm so [ __ ]
up
hey i can smell that blood
and this is one of the most fun party
games you could ever possibly play if
you want to know how to play the rules
are very simple all you need is a deck
of cards and some nerf guns and people
who generally can have a good time one
out of four people are the traitor you
count up however many people you have if
there's eight people playing that means
we have two traders deal out cards we
like to make it so we have all black
cards and the two traders are red cards
and you also have something called a
detective a detective is the one person
that everybody knows they can trust
because they are guaranteed innocent
the detective can go to any dead body
and ask them if they were a traitor or
an innocent so that is the special power
the detective gets a traitor traitor
our cdl cards people look at the cards
and keep it secret to tell if they are
traitor or innocent then what you do is
you have everybody close their eyes then
you only have the traitors open their
eyes and identify their fellow traitors
then they close their eyes and
eventually everybody reopens their eyes
what this means is that the traders know
who each other are but none of the
innocents know who the traitors are and
then it's just a game of deception and
secrecy and backstabbing until hopefully
if you're on the trader team the traders
win it's really fun every scouts we can
only see at most one or two other people
you cannot be in a group when the game
starts
i'm the detective
what are you are you allowed to ask me
that
no i mean i'm allowed to ask get out of
here what are you good
i'm not freaking good
i'm the best
all right i'm gonna start here
oh god
that means i'm the only no innocent one
left alive because there's three people
aiming guns at me right now if you guys
want to see the actual carnage head on
over to know there's a clickable thing
on the screen right now or in the
description below if you're on mobile
sam was a heck of a trader
it's like 110 degrees today
[Music]
moving is always exciting for me because
it gives you a chance to take a new
approach to doing something
and i've always liked that about life
but moving actually sucks like the
physical part of it
not fun
sitting here
and there's another person sitting here
and you can obviously put on my desk
here i think it's probably best just
roughly laying things out like
bring all the desks in here
and just continually move them around
until we find something that works
honestly that's not too far off i kind
of feel a general idea i do actually
think now would be a good time to put
some tables in and start moving them
around this is literally the worst way
to go about this let's let's do all the
physical labor without using our brain
power and then we'll use our brain power
while we do the physical labor
that's that's how they built the burj
khalifa right there
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how super saturday
i'm excited that we're gonna have more
space
oh hey there welcome to our crib
[Music]
check it out we got some nice paint and
blue paint and white paint
and invisible paint can't see that part
though we have rearranged our desks you
want to come see where the magic happens
it's over there it's definitely not
right here this is our vlogging corner
nick and carmichael were kind of spursed
out and they weren't able to communicate
effectively with synergy so now they
have this corner so carmichael can see
everything happening in the studio while
nick's editing over here and we're doing
some vfx over there let's go check it
out
you might remember the setup we had
before
[Music]
and now we have this
i finally have
a whole desk
to myself but over here in this corner
we have the american flag
yeah this this hasn't changed at all but
this corner right here this is our 3d
printing corner now so we're going to be
3d printing some cool stuff right here
while we're working over there
check out what i got
[Music]
justin
but i didn't get it you got a lot of
bodies over here where's the detective
who's our detective